on vole un tube et pour procéder après à
l'attaqué au sur le front qu'ovide les
malades sont moins nombreux mais les
décisions restent déchirante comme cet
homme dans la jeune cinquantaine
foudroyé par le virus
on pourrait devoir vous un tube et vous
plonger dans le coma lui annonce le
docteur patrick bellemare m novatrices
ils n'étaient pas vaccinés comme la
quasi totalité des patients soignés pour
l'aco vide à l'hôpital sacré coeur au
moment où on se parle et en 1/4 dans
notre clientèle puis gt4 non vaccinés il
y a moins de cas que l'hiver dernier
mais leur nombre augmente lentement on
compte 110 hospitalisation huit de plus
que lundi 33 patients sont aux soins
intensifs une augmentation de 4 par
rapport à la veille mais vu le manque de
personnel cette petite 11 ans déjà des
conséquente les deux chirurgies majeures
annulé pour cet avant midi
c'est les deux patients qu'aux vide que
j'ai dû monter en fin de nuit des
chirurgies doivent déjà être repoussée
yves campagne à se présenter à jeun à 6h
du matin mais en début d'après-midi en
lui annonce que sa chirurgie vasculaire
est annulé ce doublement de ça va parce
que jusqu'à maintenant j'imagine qu'il y
avait eu accord spécial plus urgentes le
mien qui a feinté occupants sont promis
maintenant jabra à cause l'accord les
installations sont prêtes pour affronter
une quatrième vague mais le personnel
est plus rare et plus fatigué que l'an
dernier
les livres soigner j'en sais c'est des
soignants puis on peut pas improviser
des soignants expert en soins critiques
du jour au lendemain ça fonctionne pas
comme ça l'exaspération ici est palpable
et les arguments des opposants au vaccin
sur mal reçue il ya une discussion avec
vos proches sur qu'est ce que vous
voulez comme soins si jamais ça tourne
mal tu sais c'est quoi votre niveau de
soins voulez vous qu'on fasse tout qu'on
vous intime qu'on vous prend sur une
machine où vous voulez qu'on vous
laisser aller leur pour rester
conséquent avec votre choix le type
d'argumentaire qu'on a en tant que
tellement c'est un choix individuel puis
au nom des libertés individuelles
j'ai pas à subir la vaccination mais au
nom des libertés individuelles je roule
pas à l'envers dans un one oui moi tu
ici david gêne-t-il et radio canada
montréal